bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce journal sur
tv fil 78 l'actualité locale chaque soir
du lundi au vendredi voici et les titres
de ce 15 juin à 300 lieux de collecte
proposé hier pour la journée mondiale du
don du sang l'établissement français du
sang rappelle que dix mille dons sont
nécessaires quotidiennement inviter lé
docteur denis pagès responsable du pôle
ile de france ouest à des concerts des
jeux des expositions pour la nouvelle
édition des escales d'ailleurs un
plaisir et nouveau succès avec un public
qui a répondu présent vous étiez plus de
10000 et puis guyancourt accueillait les
finales yvelinoise de handball plusieurs
matches au programme
retour sur ces rencontres et les
résultats à la fin de est cette édition
et cette information pour débuter un
prêtre de 61 ans a été interpellé à
trappes la semaine dernière ce sont nos
confrères du parisien qui rapporte cette
interpellation effectuée dans le cadre
d'une enquête comme crime qu on pour un
crime contre l'humanité l'homme proche
de l'ancien président rwandais aurait
tué entre 1,25 et 1000 étudiants dans
une université ainsi que leurs familles
une affaire qui ressurgit à plus de
vingt ans après le génocide des tutsi le
rwanda qui demande l'extradition
actuellement employé comme médiateur
social auprès d'eux à la mairie elle de
trappes 7 ab devrait pourtant rester en
france on fait le même travail on veut
les même droits c'est le message que
vous pouvez voir depuis mercredi dans le
quartier de la gare à saint quentin en
yvelines une soixantaine de travailleurs
sans papiers ont investi les locaux de
l' agence d'intérim adecco cela fait
presque une semaine et que ses salariés
à syndiqués cgt sont sur place et ils
attendent une réponse de leur direction
williams elle les a rencontrés
une opération coup de poing mercredi
dernier ces travailleurs sans papiers
ont investi l'agencé adecco de montigny
au coeur du problème des heures
supplémentaires ou des journées qui
resterait impayés ou encore des
certificats cerfa non délivrés
nécessaires à l'obtention des papiers
d'identité
c'est pour demander notre régularisation
sans condition parce que nous acquittons
de tous nos droits nos gentilles sont
les caisses de l'état français nous
payons nos impôts nous perdons nous
devons nous révolter la caisse sociale
l'a remplie sont comme tous les fastes
le fond et sans le savoir de quel droit
de retour aujourd'hui vous aidera à vous
comptez rester jusqu'à quand jusqu'à ce
que nous soyons satisfaits à 100% de nos
revendications
soutenus par la cgt mais également la
ligue des droits de l'homme depuis une
semaine ces hommes vivent et dorment sur
place en attendant un rendez vous avec
la direction
cette situation de 10 des clandestins
elle perdure parce que les lois sont
faites pour ça
tant qu'on a un moyen de pression sur
des personnes quelle qu'elle soit ici
c'est à cause de leur nationalité
quand un moyen de pression va pour faire
baisser les salaires pour les mettre en
situation de précarité effectivement pas
s'étonner c'est une exploitation pour
sortir de cette situation il n'y a pas
36 solutions il n'y a qu'une c'est
l'égalité
un problème qui se généralise dans les
agences d'intérim pour le moment aucune
rencontre n'est encore prévue avec
adecco dans les yvelines une deuxième
agence à poissy est également occupée
depuis mercredi
le parti de gauche vous l'avez vu qui
soutient donc ce mouvement et l'action
menée par la cgt la journée un mondiale
des donneurs de sang c'était ce dimanche
l'occasion d'en savoir un peu plus sur
le mode de fonctionnement d'un centre de
transfusion sanguine exemple au chesnay
où notre équipe a rencontré des donneurs
de sang mais également de plaquettes et
de plasma le reportage est signée
catherine mulato et patrick jacques de
dixmude vous êtes dans nos habitués vous
avez donné
anne-marie culine n'est pas seulement
une habituée des lieux elle donne son
sang depuis l'âge de 20 ans un geste
auquel accompli depuis bientôt 50 ans
trois à quatre fois par an c'est dire si
l'on peut donner son sang une grande
partie de sa vie
mes parents le faisaient je les fais je
continue à le faire parce que je puisse
et ce sentiment de servir à quelque
chose
vivant déjà aidé à rester vivant ici au
centre de transfusion sanguine on peut
donner donc son sang mais également ses
plaquettes ou son plasma aurélie est
donneuse de mère en fille
à 18 ans elle a suivi l'exemple
familiale seize ans plus tard elle vient
une fois par mois pour donner son plasma
un don qui dure environ 45 minutes
je sais que tout le monde on va pouvoir
aider voire sauver des vies que
n'importe qui peut en avoir besoin
six mois ont mes proches sont touchés
par un accident ou une maladie qui
demande un produit sanguin
moi je sais que j'aurai les oreilles le
plasma c'est le liquide dans lequel
baignent les cellules sanguines
le prélèvement se fait par
centrifugation il ya deux utilisations
possibles du plasma soit on fait des
transfusions de plasma en général chez
des patients qui ont des choc
hémorragique importants ou bien des
patients qui ont des maladies auto
immunes et qui ont besoin de faire des
échanges plasmatiques c'est le plasma
peut être utilisée également pour faire
des médicaments dérivés du plasma le
plasma contient beaucoup de protéines
six protéines ont des propriétés
spécifiques l'albine par exemple les
facteurs de la population ou les
immunoglobulines donc la lbu mine peut
être utilisé chez les gens qui ont des
pertes importantes à gu mine des grands
brûlés en particulier damien lui donnent
ses plaquettes
c'est aussi un constituant des cellules
sanguines le don dure 1h30 et pour cette
aide soignant yvelinois qui travaille
dans un service de chirurgie cardiaque
c'est un don essentiel travailler à
l'hôpital et souvent du mal à trouver
des dons de plaquettes et tout ça
rayon cher cardiaque et c'est compliqué
fort donc les patients essentiellement
qui sont atteints de maladies
hématologiques chronique type des
leucémies par exemple ou bien des mâts
des patients qui ont des cancers et qui
reçoivent des chimiothérapies et bien
leur taux de plaquettes peut être amené
à baisser donc il faut surveiller de
très près ce tout dès qu'ils descendent
en dessous du seuil critique il faut
faire des transfusions de plaquettes
le problème avec les plaquettes c'est
leur durée de vie les cellules doivent
être transfusé cinq jours après le don
c'est dire c'est le centre du chesnay
attend régulièrement les donneurs après
le dont les poches sont adressés un
plateau de préparation qui se trouve à
pontoise pour subir un certain nombre de
transformations
elles seront ensuite mises à la
disposition des hôpitaux ici au centre
du chéné on reçoit environ 1000
d'honneur par an en ile de france
seulement 3 à 4% les habitants donnent
leur sang et pour continuer à évoquer ce
sujet je reçois ce soir le docteur denis
pagès bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
responsable du pôle ile de france ouest
de l'établissement français du don du
sang on vient entendre à la fin de ce
reportage seulement 3 % des franciliens
qui sont donneurs c'est très peu ça
s'explique comment est-ce que c'est
propre à notre région aussi alors c'est
propre à la structure de la région c'est
à dire qu'on a des
des problèmes identiques en californie
en sels d'or funds à hambourg
c'est lié à gérer au fait que dans les
lagons mégalopole les gens font
énormément de transport et qu' ils sont
moins disponibles qu'en province
ça c'est le premier point et puis on a
moins d' associations de donneurs de
sang bénévoles c'est à dire que
quasiment en avoir autant en ile de
france que dans certains départements de
province
voilà ces gens-là nous aide beaucoup et
à tous ceux conduits au fait que même en
dépensant beaucoup d'argent pour la
communication
en tout cas sur l'île de france on
n'arrivera pas à obtenir plus de 75% des
donneurs potentiels théorique
nous sommes au lendemain de cette
journée mobilisation de mobilisation
mondiale de don du sang quel bilan vous
faites pour votre secteur alors pour
pour mon secteur ça a bien marché sans
plus nature à saint germain mais de
petits problèmes de visibilité parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses sur
l'ensemble de l'île de france
c'est un franc succès puisque on avait
prévu de mille et quelques personnes à
se présenter candidat et on a eu
beaucoup plus et on a fait quelque chose
comme 2000 quelques prélèvements dont
750 nouveaux donneurs les chiffres je
veux juste rappeler un détail on peut
donner pour les hommes 6 fois par an
pour les femmes quatre fois paris
absolue c'est ça quelle explication
parce que le
la physiologie de la femme entre son
cycle hormonal et sa physiologie fait
qu' elles consomment plus de globules
rouges elles absorbent moins bien le
faire elle le fixe moins bien elle mange
moins de viande aussi et donc elle est
souvent limite de l'année mais en plus
tu entends le 11 avril des squatteurs
qu'on appelle des bébés et qu'ils
prennent dans leurs réserves et le met
un certain temps donc il faut protéger
la physiologie de la femme qui régénère
moins facilement allez savoir pourquoi
ça sent quand cependant des réseaux
hormonal mais moins facilement ces
globules rouges que les hommes et c'est
pour ça qu'on aime bien les hommes
d'une part parce qu'on peut les voir
plus souvent et d'autre part on peut
prélever un peu plus que chez les femmes
en moyenne
ça c'est pour le sens lié à la question
des plaquettes et de plasma aussi et là
on peut donner plus souvent alors oui
sur le placement on peut donner tous les
quinze jours on peut de faire un par
exemple on peut faire un nom on a pu
faire un don du sang hier dimanche et
quinze jours plus tard on peut très bien
donner son plasma mais il faut quelqu'un
joue entre chaque don de plasma entre
deux dons de sang il faut une semaine
voilà les plaquettes en à peu près dans
les quinze jours trois semaines fois
tant que ça
mais on prend des rendez-vous alors
l'intérêt danse on l'a vu là sur votre
reportage au chesnay c'est qu'on prend
rendez-vous à la différence des
collectes mobiles donc à la grée l'aicto
mobile bon c'est pas trop quand est ce
que les gens vont arriver vous pouvez
attendre alors qu'en sites fixes
vous avez un rendez vous est pris en
charge immédiatement et c'est toujours à
moins de gros ennuis mais les gens sont
reçus au moment où ils arrivent et au
moment prévu puisque là vous avez évoqué
la question du plasma j'aimerais qu'on
ouvre une petite parenthèse parce qu'il
ya quelques difficultés que rencontre
actuellement à l'établissement français
du sang l'établissement français du sang
est face à un défi par une décision de
la cour de justice européenne le plasma
que nous produisions a été classé comme
médicament et non pas comme produits
sanguins labiles moyennant quoi nous
n'avons plus le droit de d'appliquer ces
traitements au plasma que nous prélevons
puisque c'est assimilé à un processus
pharmaceutique et que le ffs n'est pas
établissements pharmaceutiques
le problème c'est que le laboratoire
européen qui a fait cette requête lui ne
produit que ce type de plasma est donc
comme il ne fait pas de recherche comme
il ne va pas faire des prélèvements de
globules rouges qu'il ne fait pas de
prélèvement de plaquettes qu'il n'a pas
de coopération internationale qui n'a
pas de formation
et bien c'est vrai que ces coûts de
production sont largement moins élevés
que les nôtres
et comme les hôpitaux ont l'obligation
de faire des appels d'offres ça veut
dire que si nous ne réussissons pas avec
l'aide des donneurs et des nouveaux
donneurs à mettre en place ce qu'on
faisait d'ailleurs il ya 20 ans le
plasma sécurisé et bien là on risque
d'avoir beaucoup de soucis au niveau de
la ffs et au niveau de le gérer
l'autosuffisance en france et ce système
là permettrait de contourner le passage
sous forme de deux laboratoires pour le
fs pour fondre et de recherche alors 11
ans du plasma sécuriser le placement
sécurisé ça consiste simplement à
demander à un donneur de revenir entre
40 et 120 jours depuis son dernier dont
même allé minutes on a fait une prise de
sang ont fait les examens biologiques et
bactériologiques à rien le plasma sans
aucun traitement et d'y sécuriser et
donc on peut le donner
un patient sans aucun problème c'est un
vrai dilemme en fait qui va se poser
aujourd'hui c'est si les passions ne
joue pas ce jeu-là ce système là on
passe dans une marchandisation un petit
peu vu son comble entre laboratoires
pharmaceutiques c'est rémunère ces
donneurs de plasma mais s'est engagé à
ne pas fournir de placements rémunérés
en france puisque nous voulons garder
notre caractère éthique bénévole et sans
profit mais le fait qu'on accepte que en
europe 1 dont deux ne serait-ce que de
plasma soit rémunéré c'est quand même
quelque part un pas vers la
marchandisation c'était aucune raison de
ne pas vendre une cornée un brin tous
les organes qu'on peut avoir besoin pour
faire des greffes et ça c'est quand même
j'ai inquiétant dans derrière cette
journée de mobilisation de dons il y
avait cette question là aussi qui reste
en suspens le défi de l'avenir un petit
peu pour prendre habilement français le
système de fonctionnement
je crois que le f s en tout cas les
équipes sur le terrain partout en france
se met en branle vraiment son se sont
elles concernées parce que ça va
entraîner des réductions de personnel
aussi assisté réussit pas on parle d'au
moins 10% de réduction de personnel sur
dix mille personnes ça fait quand même
pas mal
les associations sont mobilisées aussi
est en fait si on veut continuer à
fournir à nos patients les enfants les
adultes qu'on ne connaît pas ou qu'on
connaît des produits sanguins pour tous
leurs besoins et pas uniquement le
plasma et bien si on arrive avec les
gommes heures à relever ce défi
on a en plus gagner quelque chose au
plan éthique et moral les donneurs
justement donner votre sang
régulièrement c'est notre question du
jour vos réponses ça m'est jamais arrivé
parce que je crois qu'il faut faire 45
kg pour donner son sang tu les fais pas
et en plus des jouets en aiguille je
tombe dans les pommes moi j'ai fait une
fois et je pourrais le refaire je
conseille à beaucoup de gens de le faire
j'ai eu un père leucémiques donc soit ni
à sa louis donc à partir de 18 ans je
les fais non je ne m'en sors pas ce que
leur foi je les donne et j'ai perdu
connaissance j'étais pas très bien non
pas du tout que j'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de le faire ou le courage de
prendre du temps pour ça non parce que
je peux et l'occasion non je donne pas à
mon sens non pas parce que je n'ai pas
encore fait la carte de donneur et j'y
pense sérieusement pourquoi pas
prochainement je les ai jamais fait mais
je compte le faire sur facebook
aujourd'hui j'ai vu que c'était la
journée du don du sang donc je vais le
faire les petites précisions vous me le
disait pendant le micro-trottoir la
carte de donneur on l'a après la
complétion y aller directement de dons
pour vérifier s'assurer que le groupe
sanguin déterminer les bons et puis pour
la dame il faut peser au moins 50 kg pas
45 et avoir 18 ans alors qu'elle ait
quelques petits détails qui sont tout de
même importants vous voulez à vous aussi
à franchir le pas à donner votre sang
notamment il ya encore beaucoup de
restrictions qui s'appliquent
aujourd'hui pour le don du sang
justement il ya deux types de contre
indications et les contres ication
temporaires qui sont liées au voyage par
exemple dans des pays acp palud et le
fait que vous ayez eu un examen du type
coloscopie sa demande quatre mois pour
être sûr de n'avoir aucune bactérie dans
le sens parce que le donneur qui est
quand même en bonne santé ses valises
éliminé par contre quand vous donnez
quelqu'un qui n'est plus de globules
blancs quand vous avez une deux
bactéries ça suffit pour faire une
septicémie donc en fait ce qui est
anodin chez le donneur peut être
gravissimes
il ya des contre indications qui sont
liées à la santé du donneur
on ne veut pas prendre par exemple de
diabétiques traités par l'insuline c'est
pas la peine de mettet désordre là
dedans
les gens qui sont traitées pour
hypertension artérielle avec deux trois
produits
on va pas jouer à ça non plus donc et
puis vous avez des contre-indications
permanentes ya les gens qui ont dans
leur famille quelqu'un que fait de malik
tressel jacob
vous avez des gens qui ont été
transfusés pour des raisons de principe
de précaution les homosexuels également
vous pose la question parce que dans le
dernier communiqué un tout récent de
l'association sos homophobie une fois de
plus elle appelle à l' égalité puisque
pour l'instant les homosexuels sont
toujours interdits black ses oeuvres le
dossier est sur le bureau de madame
marisol touraine autres ministres les
parlementaires
même si c'est pas tellement leur secteur
de responsabilité ont pris une décision
fin les en beauté en effet plus de
discrimination à travers la
rationalisation ne serait ce que par je
dirais correction professionnels moi je
n'applique le vrai qu appliquer les
décisions
je ne vous livrerai pas
mon sentiment ma vie est là dessus
puisque voilà je représente les faits
c'est donc sans vouloir faire de langage
de bois
j'espère qu'on va trouver une solution
intelligente
ou une réponse intelligente à ces deux
questions pour terminer cet entretien
une dernière qu'elles sont qu'elles sont
en question pardon quels sont les
besoins d'ici à la période de l'été on
sait c'est toujours une période plutôt
plutôt difficile surtout sur notre
secteur les gens quittent la région
oui alors ben il ya qu un peu valeur cgc
est intéressant par exemple la partie s
de paris fonctionne bien
pendant les vacances d'été pour le mans
parce que les gens ont moins d'argent
pour poser place et moi je demande aux
gens cet été notamment dans les deux
premières semaines d'août
s'ils voient une collecte mobile ou
s'ils veulent être aux frais téléphoner
un site fixe parce qu'ensuite fixot
financier du don de sang total et puis
venir donner pour éviter qu'on soir dans
l'obligation une nouvelle fois de faire
des appels aux dons
ce qui est désagréable et ce qui n'est
pas forcément flatteur pour
l'établissement français du sang
merci docteur denis pagès responsable du
pôle ile de france ouest de
l'établissement français du don du fonds
merci à vous y sentez toujours et la
nouvelle édition du forum santé
bien-être de saint quentin en yvelines
il vient de se refermer à l'espace saint
quentin à montigny-le-bretonneux bilan
objectif avec florane parfait un peu de
zumba pour prendre soin de sa santé ça
peut tout changer au forum santé et
bien-être de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un des messages que l'on veut
faire passer avec ces initiations
sportives voix au fur et à mesure de mon
activité de mon métier que le plus
enfants du sport buisson dans leur vie
quotidienne comme on est bien dans son
corps bien dans sa tête c'est toujours
les mots qu'on emploie
si vous n'avez pas mal au dos vous êtes
plus plus tranquille plus libres pour
pour faire vos mouvements et la vie tous
les jours des ateliers tai-chi du body
pump ou du pilote était proposée ce
week-end comme chaque année un fort mais
reste le premier objectif du forum
la nouveauté de cette édition une façon
de plus positif de parler de la santé on
a élargi la notion de santé à la notion
de santé et bien-être
puisqu'on est réservée santé oms depuis
i 6 et à ce titre en fait on a l'idée de
la santé s'est pas seulement liée au
physique mais aussi à l'émotionnel au
psy chic à différentes composantes et en
ce sens on a convié des structures qui
travaillent autour des notions de
bien-être les acteurs habituels de la
santé étaient également présents près
d'un millier de personnes sont venues
chercher des renseignements sur les
différents établissements de santé du
territoire ou même parfois se faire
dépister
comme ici sur le stand de l'association
des diabétiques des yvelines
aujourd'hui le diabète touche plus de 3
5 millions de personnes à travers le
monde en france 700 mille individus
s'ignorent ce qui est un chiffre
relativement conséquents ce qui veut
dire que sur les deux jours où nous
sommes présents sur le forum de santé à
saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes amenés à dépister des gens
qui s'ignore nombreux sont ceux qui se
rendent à li ps après ce premier contact
l'institut de promotion de la santé
accueille chaque année 8000 personnes
des forums itinérants sont prévues
prochainement à magny les hameaux et à
elancourt politique et la réélection de
sandrine grand gambe à la tête du parti
socialiste des yvelines la conseillère
régionale et municipale de trappes a
obtenu un peu plus de 63% des voix sans
surprise élu depuis à 2012 elle va donc
mener la prochaine campagne électorale
des régionales de décembre charge à
elles d'inverser la tendance après les
revers aux municipales et aux as
départementale et puis la polémique
entre benoît hamon et jean michel
fourgous la semaine dernière le député
socialiste de la 11e circonscription
annoncé avoir obtenu le déblocage de
fonds de la part de l'état pour une
étude sur la réalisation d'un nouveau
commissariat elancourt faux répond le
maire de la ville a du parti des
républicains a par ailleurs premier
adjoint de la casse qui la demande a été
faite par le préfet ce sont les
événements à dramatique de ces dernières
semaines qui ont décidé le ministre de
l'intérieur jean michel fourgous elle de
rappeler que l'agglomération sera le
principal financeur il évoque une
démarche électoraliste de la part de
benoît hamon la campagne des
législatives 2017 qui semble d'ores et
déjà bel et bien ouverte plus léger le
mois de juin le mois des festivals la
commune de plaisir ne déroge pas à la
règle et en ce samedi ensoleillé ce sont
plus de dix mille visiteurs et qui sont
venus assister à la nouvelle édition est
d'escale d'ailleurs mélanie et poker
on croiser de drôles d'énergumènes à
plaisir ce week-end pour sa 13e édition
le festival escales d'ailleurs invité au
voyage proches comme lointain talent
origines joséphine coleman berger qui
était précédemment notre élue à la
culture a eu l'idée d'une fête comme ça
qui avait l'objet de rassembler tous les
quartiers de la ville en un lieu unique
un lieu vraiment privilégié favorables
que ce parc du château qui était pas
forcément très connus de notre public
plaisir voix et donc qui par le biais
donc de ce festival le découvre tout en
découvrant ses voisins et ses amis et
avec ce thème de l'invitation au voyage
aussi en profitent pour découvrir les
cultures du monde
le voyage passant aussi par la
découverte gastronomique plusieurs
associations plaisir oise cuisiner mais
portugais malien congolais ou encore
mauritanien dans notre stand nous
proposons plusieurs mythes notamment les
makeba j'appelle ça est
traditionnellement sinon ce sont les
bananes plantains nous avons lâché coin
c1 mais sur base de du manioc nous
proposons aussi les beignets c'est un
menu typiquement africain c'est très
important parce que c'est de retrouver
tous les détenus tous les ressortissants
de retrouver ses déambulations
démonstrations de danses concerts mais
aussi de traditionnel jeu proposé par
les services de la ville et la
quarantaine d'associations mobilisées
pour l'occasion
de quoi ravir petits et grands bah c'est
super c'est bien parce que les jeux sans
vraiment très ludique on n'en trouve pas
partout des jeux comme ça alors ce qui
est dommage c'est qu'on a fait beaucoup
de queue et pour tout le temps faim pour
peu de jeu on est resté deux heures sur
trampoline
mais sinon c'est une bonne ambiance et
c'est super on a de la chance alors
qu'il fasse beau ce qui allait bien il
ya plusieurs l'activité bat je m'amuse
bien que cette année encore près de dix
mille personnes ont fait le déplacement
on passe aux sports et du handball à
guyancourt samedi et dimanche deux jours
pour déterminer les différents champions
dans les différentes catégories du
département des yvelines sur place
maxime le maine quatre équipes engagées
pour la s mentent sur dix rencontres le
club du nord du département bien présent
lors de ces finales de la coupe des
yvelines de handball organisé à
guyancourt le week-end gagne et ça
prouve que l'industrie entraîneur au
niveau des jeunes autistes ou non mais
ça faisait longtemps qu'on n'a pas
représenté au temps de l'équipe féminine
parce qu'il ya des banques qu'on est
dans sa catégorie on avait une équipe ça
fait quelques années où on a voilà mais
cette année voilà on est content de
retrouver le haut niveau en coupe davis
montalet
une forte habitude à jouer a évolué au
niveau champion de france donc ils sont
redescendus la saison passée dont ils
ont déjà une culture handballistique et
puis traditionnellement chez les jeunes
chez les jeunes filles notamment
c'est une tradition donc d'avoir des
équipes de bon niveau monte qui repart
de la compétition avec un titre en moins
de 11 ans mixte et un titre en plus de
16 ans féminin remporté face à poissy le
handball se porte bien dans le
département et en france avec plus de 51
mille licenciés et aujourd'hui
l'ambition et surtout de faire
progresser les sections féminines dans
l'ensemble des clubs comme à poissy nous
cette année en craie à poissy un pôle
féminin justement
pour sur le bassin pour pouvoir dire
amener nos jeunes au plus haut niveau
on avait une équipe de moins de 15 ans
l'entente 418 avec asher en finale de la
coupe également
donc on en train de construire j'allais
dire un vivier de jeunes filles pour le
handball
avec des entraîneurs
je veux dire très compétent niveau de la
formation de son côté guyancourt ne
présentait qu'une équipe dans la
compétition justement chez les féminines
en moins de 17 ans mais en tant
qu'organisateur il s'agissait surtout
d'exposer sa capacité à gérer
l'événement avec une salle le gymnase
des droits de l'homme pouvant accueillir
jusqu'à 450 spectateurs mais les
différents résultats on notera aussi la
victoire de versailles sur plaisir en
moins de 13 ans masculins plaisir qui
l'emportent
en revanche en plus de 16 ans masculins
face à matt se porte toujours une
journée de sensibilisation au golf pour
promouvoir la ryder cup 2018 a eu lieu
jeudi dernier au stade gravaud avec les
écoles de trappes le reportage de
sephora namani un club en main une balle
a frappé le but se rapprocher du drapeau
avec le moins de coups possible
vu comme ça ça paraît simple c'est
difficile mais c'est amusant parce que
sans travail du président précision le
plus dur c'est d'arriver dans un premier
temps à toucher la balle et puis après
arriver à doser en fait ces coupes pas
taper trop fort est arrivé à au fur et à
mesure à se rapprocher du drapeau des
fois on s'était achète mais des fois ça
vient tout seul sa part ce point est
refaite
c'est quand on fait quand on essaye de
tirer la balle et en fait ça passe juste
au dessus de la vallée sa touche pas ça
m'énerve aussi ça stresse une journée de
sensibilisation ou golf à destination
des écoles a été organisée sur toutes
les communes de saint quentin pour
promouvoir la ryder cup 2018
pas facile mais amusant nombreux sont
les qualités requises pour jouer au golf
c'est de la concentration beaucoup de
concentration beaucoup de coordination
donc arriver à coordonner ses bras ses
jambes pour arriver à faire un mouvement
qui est pas forcément pas forcément
simple et
donc voilà c'est beaucoup des guides
d'éducation civique aussi respect
respect des joueurs du parcours du
matériel donc ça en fait ça apporte
énormément de choses incarnez
pédagogique a même été créé pour
l'occasion en partenariat avec la
fédération française de golf et
l'éducation nationale pour faire
découvrir ce sport au travers de
différentes matières scolaires fin de
journée à la suivre sur tv fil 78 7 8
sport avec michael et demi d'euros le 7
8 force consacré ajustements au golf a
loué la veille puisque ce sera le 2
juillet de l'ouverture de l'open de
france je vous retrouve demain mardi aux
horaires habituels très belle soirée